Новини дня «heute» з Барбарою Гальвеґ.
Добрий вечір.
Новини спорту сьогодні розповість Норберт Кеніґ.
Головні теми випуску:
Німеччина потерпає від спеки.
Через екстремальні температури
страждають насамперед люди похилого віку.
У Бранденбурзі пожежники борються
з наслідками спеки.
Два нові лідери AfD: Тіно Хрупалла
знову обраний співочільником партії.
Він переміг, отримавши незначну більшість голосів.
Співголовою партії стала Аліс Вайдель.
Жорстка критика на відкритті виставки «Documenta»:
президент Німеччини
Штайнмаєр незадоволений тим,
що не запросили митців з Ізраїлю.
На щастя, сьогодні субота, тож у більшості
й так вихідний. Для інших це вихідний через спеку.
Метеорологічна служба Німеччини
попереджає, що впродовж вихідних
очікуються екстремальні температури.
За словами кліматологів,
така температура стане звичною у майбутньому.
На синоптичній карті зображено
розподіл температур у Німеччині.
На Півночі - помірно тепла погода,
а ось в решті країни - жахлива спека.
Насамперед це стосується регіону між
Верхнім Рейном та Східним Бранденбургом.
На термометрі - 37°.
Про найспекотніший день цього року
детальніше розповість Зандра Зузанка.
Сьогодні багатьом хотілося лише охолодитися.
Не лише тут, у Штутґарті, а у всій Німеччині.
Відкриті басейни переповнені, показники
ультрафіолетового випромінювання високі.
Майже по всій країні попереджають про спеку.
У Штутгарті майже 36°.
Спекотне північноафриканське повітря,
відчутне відсьогодні особливо в містах,
ледве можна витримати.
Ми рухаємося дуже повільно і шукаємо затінки.
Також п'ємо багато води.
Щоправда, затінки зустрічаються доволі рідко,
тож тіснимося тут на лавці.
Мені навіть здається, що спека
стає дедалі більш нестерпною.
Сьогодні я теж це помітила,
хоча ще не так спекотно, як я очікувала.
Це також свідчить про те, що
через зміну клімату змінюється і світ.
Адже зараз лише червень, а вже так спекотно.
Жахлива спека становить загрозу
навіть для статики будинку.
Мешканці житлового будинку у
Дюссельдорфі вимушені евакуюватися,
адже під впливом високих температур
сталева балка дуже розширилася.
Внаслідок цього у кам'яній кладці з'явилися тріщини.
Насамперед від спеки страждають такі люди,
як покрівельники.
Покрівельник Май Кюнер з Дессау працює й у вихідні.
Дах швидко нагрівається до 60°-70°.
Знизу тепло віддає крівля, а згори - сонце.
Доводиться працювати на межі сил.
Тілу важко вмить пристосуватися
до мінливих температур.
Тому варто зважати на його сигнали.
Передусім це стосується кровообігу.
Людина відчуває запаморочення, їй зле.
Іноді ці сигнали важко розпізнати.
Тому варто зважати на них і пити
достатньо рідини, хоч це і складно.
У Шлезвіґ-Гольштейні, на пляжі, люди насолоджуються
першим спекотним днем на Балтійському морі.
Тут температура помірно тепла і становить 28°.
Сьогодні там легко можна витримати
спеку завдяки прохолодному вітерцю.
Якщо ми не будемо протидіяти зміні клімату,
доведеться звикнути до
екстремальних погодних умов.
У Німеччині вже помітні наслідки спеки та посухи:
води стає дедалі менше, а ось
небезпека лісових пожеж навпаки зростає.
Чому ці проблеми наразі актуальні,
наприклад, для Бранденбургу?
Детальніше про це розповість Катрін Лінднер.
У Фронсдорфі, на південь від Берліна,
спалахнула лісова пожежа.
Гасити її можна лише на відстані.
В землі повно боєприпасів з
часів двох світових воєн.
Досі горять близько 40 га лісу.
У цьому році в Бранденбурзі
сталося 220 лісових пожеж.
Сьогодні по всій країні ми оголосили п'ятий,
найвищий, рівень небезпеки лісових пожеж.
Тобто така небезпека існує у кожному районі.
Річка Шпрее поблизу міста Котбус має важливе
значення для водопостачання Берліна.
Вже зараз існує потреба у додатковій воді з гребель.
У місті Котбус заборонили впродовж дня
використовувати воду з річок та озер,
наприклад, для поливу городів.
Минулого року це сталося, здається,
аж наприкінці липня.
Проте цього року
була дуже посушлива весна.
Ми вимірюємо загальний
рівень ґрунтових вод у регіоні.
Наразі він на 80 см нижче за
рівень у минулі роки.
Котбузьке «Балтійське море» на півночі від міста
колись було найбільшим
штучним озером Німеччини.
Підняття рівня води припинилося.
Це знову може статися лише
восени, коли буде більше води.
Втім, сьогодні на це більше не можна покладатися.
Певною мірою тенденція, яку ми
спостерігаємо впродовж останніх десятиліть,
набагато сильніша, аніж нам прогнозують
кліматичні моделі для цього періоду.
Тобто у реальному світі
все набагато екстремальніше.
Ті, хто зараз у Бранденбурзі,
вже зараз відчувають суттєвість зміни клімату.
Війна ще більше ускладнює захист клімату.
Оскільки Росія постачає дедалі менше газу,
Німеччина повинна знайти альтернативи.
Наприклад, заощаджувати газ під час
виробництва електроенергії.
Наразі 31,5% електроенергії, що
виробляється та подається у Німеччині,
отримують, спалюючи вугілля.
Ще 30% електроенергії
генерують завдяки енергії вітру.
13% припадає на природний газ.
Багато хто вважає, що частка газу має
й надалі зменшуватися.
Водночас, попри шкоду для клімату, наполягають
на більшій кількості вугілля.
Детальніше про це розповість Даніель Понтцен.
Промисловість має намір
збільшити використання вугілля.
Федеральне об'єднання німецької промисловості
вимагає негайно вивести
вугільні електростанції з резерву
і вже зараз припинити використання
газу для виробництва електроенергії.
Зігфрід Руссвурм зазначає:
«Якщо ситуація із поставками справді буде
такою ж складною,
як здається зараз, необхідно
негайно скористатися цим варіантом».
Імпорт електроенергії з сусідніх країн має межу.
CDU/CSU підтримує цю ідею.
Втім, вони не виступають проти пропозиції
міністра економіки знизити
температуру опалення у квартирах.
Якщо буде потреба, закріпивши це в законі.
Останніми днями я не помітив,
щоб у квартирах були зависокі температури.
І я вважаю, що перш ніж пан Габек
запропонує громадянам мерзнути,
варто зробити те,
що в силах держави,
а саме використовувати більше вугільних
електростанцій, щоб заощадити газ на зиму.
У  «Greenpeace» вважають,
що раціональний підхід до опалення - це добре.
Втім, політика також має сприяти
заощадженню газу і в промисловості.
Наприклад, завдяки кращій ізоляції
та встановленню теплових насосів.
Незрозуміло, як швидко буде видно
результат цих змін.
Тим паче, що ще потрібно провести голосування
в межах «світлофорної коаліції».
Заощадження енергії – хороша ідея.
Чи потрібно закріпити це у законодавстві -
під знаком питання.
Важливо, щоб ми комфортно пережили зиму
і як держава зробили усе для забезпечення
енергетичної безпеки у Німеччині.
Усі згодні із поставленою метою. Проте питання,
як її досягти, залишається відкритим.
Що більше Росія скорочує поставки,
то більший тиск щодо ухвалення рішення.
Дивіться детальне інтерв'ю з очільником
Федерального об'єднання німецької промисловості
завтра у програмі «Berlin direkt»
одразу після «heute» о 19:10.
Схід та Захід, чоловік та жінка, ремісник та академік.
Тепер Тіно Хрупалла та Аліс Вайдель очолюють
не лише фракцію AfD у парламенті, але й саму партію.
Учасники партійного з'їзду у Різі обрали
політичний дует співголовами партії.
Однак прихильність делегатів
розподілилася дуже нерівномірно.
Детальніше розповість Крістіана Гюбшер.
Так, я визнаю результати виборів.
Тіно Хрупалла отримав від AfD ще один шанс.
Він новий старий голова,
хоч і переміг, набравши лише 53% голосів.
Аліс Вайдель стала новою співголовою.
Разом вони мають знову поставити партію на ноги.
Сьогодні ми залишаємо минуле позаду.
Ми не будемо озиратися назад.
Ера Йорга Мойтена також закінчилася сьогодні.
Опонент Хрупалли Норберт Кляйнвехтер намагався
зробити іншу пропозицію щодо так
званої фракції помірності «Flügel».
Нам потрібно терміново вибиратися
з того занепаду, де ми зараз є.
Завдяки новій політичній
комунікації, новому стилю.
Завдяки новому вітру змін, щоб
виборці також бачили,
що в AfD відбувається щось позитивне.
Він привернув увагу публіки, але не більше.
Аліс Вайдель отримала
більше голосів, ніж Хрупалла - 67%.
Вона присягнулася у вірності та дисципліні AfD,
ослабленій через низку поразок у виборах.
Хто з нас справді думав,
що у такого проєкту як AfD не буде промахів?
Було цілком зрозуміло, що
імперія завдасть удару у відповідь.
Ми відреагуємо на це.
Бйорн Геке Ґнаден, співголова AfD у Тюрингії,
відомий правий екстреміст та
голова земельного парламенту Тюрингії
відверто смикає за ниточки тут, у Різі.
Також він підтримує й інших, раніше обраних членів
партійного керівництва.
Федеральне правління партії поки що
повністю мене влаштовує.
Я з обережністю оптимістично припускаю,
що на цій посаді будуть наші товариші по партії,
які мають міцний характер та
твердий намір співпрацювати.
Для цього іншим доведеться звільнити місце.
Під час цього з'їзду партії керівництво AfD
вирішило й надалі «рухатися праворуч».
Ніколь Дікманн наразі перебуває у Різі.
Чого варто очікувати від
нового партійного керівництва?
Очевидно, що AfD схилилася праворуч.
З одного боку - щойно переобраний Тіно Хрупалла.
З іншого - Аліс Вайдель,
яка вперше обійматиме цю посаду.
Вона отримала значно кращий результат.
Тож існує висока ймовірність виникнення конфлікту
між двома очільниками,
які зараз мають об'єднати.
розсварену та ослаблену низкою поразок
на виборах партію AfD.
У Хрупалли та Вайдель є кілька спільних рис.
Вони хочуть, щоб все було єдиним, і не заперечують
наявність правих екстремістів в об'єднанні.
Федеральна служба захисту Конституції Німеччини
вже декілька місяців
спостерігає за AfD через схильність партії
до правоекстремізму.
Бйорн Геке не приховує, що підтримує
правоекстремістські ідеї.
Геке зіграв важливу роль у виборах очільників партії,
що досі тривають позаду мене.
Прихильники правоекстремізму демонструють сьогодні
весь масштаб їхньої влади.
Так звані «помірні» не мають шансів.
Ніколь Дікманн з партійних зборів AfD у Різі.
Міністр юстиції Бушманн
висловив скептичне ставлення
до повторного запровадження
обов'язкового носіння масок,
якщо інфекції коронавірусу
продовжать різко зростати.
Очевидно, він не вважає їхню користь
науково доведеною.
Він хоче дочекатися результатів експертної ради,
сказав Бушманн газеті «Rheinische Post».
Швидка критика з боку
Всесвітньої медичної асоціації -
ефективність носіння масок науково доведена,
каже президент Монтгомері газеті «Funke Mediengruppe».
114 день війни:
у багатьох містах на сході України, як і раніше,
тривають запеклі бої.
За даними українських джерел,
російські війська намагаються
оточити Сєвєродонецьк.
Тим часом президент Зеленський відвідав
прифронтове місто Миколаїв.
Після запеклих боїв українським солдатам вдалося
витіснити звідти російські війська.
Минуло вже майже 11 років
від дня масового вбивства
на норвезькому острові Утея.
На пам’ять про жертв тепер встановлено меморіал:
77 триметрових стовпів.
По одному для кожного з загиблих,
серед яких були переважно молоді люди.
Разом з принцом Хоконом сім'ї загиблих та постраждалі
відкрили меморіал на острові.
Правий екстреміст Брейвік розстріляв
69 учасників політичного літнього табору,
а раніше вбив 8 людей бомбою в Осло.
Протягом наступних 100 днів
світ мистецтва дивиться на Кассель -
сьогодні відбулося відкриття однієї з найважливіших
виставок сучасного мистецтва «Documenta»,
яка проходить лише раз на п’ять років.
Цього року у центрі уваги - Південь нашої планети,
найбідніші регіони світу.
На відкритті пролунала й критика
від президента Німеччини.
Більше від Пітера Тайзена.
Коли федеральний президент
відвідує виставку «Documenta»,
передбачається, що в його промові
йтиметься про мистецтво.
Однак після перегляду деяких робіт
Штайнмаєр розкритикував
організаторів виставки, заявивши,
що вони настільки байдуже
поставилися до антисемітизму,
що він подумав взагалі не приїжджати.
Свобода думок і свобода мистецтва
лежать в основі нашої конституції.
Критикувати Ізраїль не заборонено,
але коли критика Ізраїлю
переходить в критику його існування,
це вже недопустимо.
Бойкот Ізраїлю рівносильний
заперечення його існування.
Кураторія, індонезійський митецький колектив,
запросив палестинських художників,
але не ізраїльських.
У серії картин Ґерніка Ґази на виставці «Documenta»
критично осмислюються дії Ізраїлю
на палестинських територіях.
Кураторія, як й організатори «Documenta»
дистанціюються від антисемітизму.
Ми серйозно ставимося до
історичної відповідальності Німеччини.
Ми також вважаємо це важливою темою.
Митці теж дуже уважно
піднімають її.
Просто тематика цієї виставки
орієнтується більше на майбутнє.
І тому така тематизація
німецького минулого
на даній виставці просто не є в програмі.
Основна тема «Documenta» -
перспективи Півдня планети.
Це вперше, що я відчуваю,
що меж між відвідувачем і виставкою немає,
що можна заглибитися у все.
Я відчула себе у 80-х роках,
коли ми виконували громадську роботу.
Виставка нагадала мені про це.
Тепер мені цікаво подивитись, що буде далі.
На 100 днів Кассель стає центром світу мистецтва.
Нарешті після двох років коронавірусних обмежень
Кільський тиждень повертається
до колишньої форми та розміру.
Народне свято для жителів Кіля та їх гостей:
мільйони людей очікують на
дев'ять днів вітрильної регати,
парад Вінджамерів і «Bunte Meile».
На півночі святу сприяє й погода.
Понад 30° на тенісному турнірі в Галле, Вестфалія,
який, на жаль, закінчився для Оскара Отте.
Норберте, але ж він не полегшив
завдання своєму супернику.
Його гра стала б випробуванням
й для зірок Вімблдону.
Він програв першому номеру світового рейтингу,
але набрався впевненості в собі.
Тільки в пів фіналі Оскар Отте може
привітати свого суперника -
Данііл Мєдвєдєв у вирішальні моменти брав гору.
Це не була сенсація, але ще довго Оскар Отте
буде на рівні із переможцями.
Тенісист з Кельна, як і завжди,
захопив 11 000 глядачів
видовищним матчем.
Його гра була впевненою та багатою на варіації.
Тільки на тай-брейку
після більш ніж годинної перерви
Данііл Мєдвєдєв виграв перший сет.
Росіянин зміг досягти успіху
і в другому сеті.
Мєдвєдєв перемагає з рахунком 7:3 та 6:3.
Шкода, я б хотів потрапити у фінал,
але, можливо, наступного року.
Визнання з боку суперника за успішний тиждень.
На своєму першому турнірі в Галле
Оскар Отте переміг
трьох кращих гравців і тепер може впевнено
вирушити на Вімблдон.
Леоні Еберт - чемпіонка Європи з фехтування.
Спортсменка від Team Future Fencing Werbach
виграла у фіналі в італійки Аріанни Ерріго
в Анталії з рахунком 15:11,
а її колега по команді - Анна Зауер посіла п’яте місце.
На початку Чемпіонату світу з плавання в Римі
вже перша медаль для Німеччини -
Лукас Мертенс з СК «Магдебург» завоював срібло
на дистанції 400 метрів вільним стилем.
Як найкращий за рік на трьох довгих дистанціях
вільним стилем
Мертенс виходить у свій
перший фінал чемпіонату світу.
Зрештою, 20-річний спортсмен поступився
австралійцю Елайджа Віннінгтону на 1,63 секунди.
Медаль Чемпіонату світу, здобута Мартенсом,
стала першою для Німеччини
на цій дистанції за останні 11 років.
І на Чемпіонаті світу з параплавання на Майдері
Таня Шольц закінчує свій
успішний виступ на п'ятому місці.
Шольц, з паралічем обох кінцівок після
нещасного випадку під час верхової їзди 2 роки тому,
здобула свій третій титул на дистанції 200 м
вільним стилем у класі S4
на цьому чемпіонаті світу.
Спортсменка з Ельмсгорна дебютувала
з результатом 02:53:02 -
успіх на омріяному чемпіонаті світу.
ФК «Баварія» Мюнхен продовжує боротися
за звання чемпіона Німеччини з баскетболу
завдяки несподівано чистій перемозі
у третьому матчі фіналу плей-офф
у команди «Альба Берлін».
На подив 14 500 глядачів
мюнхенці в червоному, не маючи запасних гравців,
вражаюче перервали серію берлінців
з 19 безпрограшних матчів.
19 дивовижних очок
найкращого бомбардира Ніка Вайлер-Бабба
допомогли здобути перемогу з рахунком 90:60.
Завтрашня гра в Мюнхені - другий матчбол для берлінців
Його називають Моцартом ХХ століття,
і сьогодні йому виповнилося 80 років.
Голос сера Пола Маккартні став трохи грубішим,
але його музика не старішає.
Разом з «The Beatles» він написав нову сторінку
в історії музики,
сформував ціле покоління.
Навіть сьогодні він їздить на гастролі так,
ніби група була заснована
всього кілька років, а не більше півстоліття тому.
Скільки ще триватиме спека
і де завтра очікуються грози,
розповість за хвилину Катя Горнеффер.
Крістіан Зіверс чекає з випуском
«heute journal» о 22:45.
Дякуємо за ваш інтерес,
бажаємо гарного вечора
і сподіваємося побачити вас знову завтра.
До побачення.
Добрий вечір.
Сьогодні не по всій Німеччині
було справді спекотно.
На півночі цей маленький холодний фронт
вже відчутний.
Температура на Зюльті була лише 18°,
коли в Єні було 36°, а в Бад-Кройцнаху 37°.
Ця різниця температур також помітна вночі.
На півночі температура знизиться до 11°-14°.
Ніч залишиться тропічною між
Західною Саксонією і Сааром.
Там температура не опуститься нижче 20°.
Загалом очікується ясна погода.
Цей маленький холодний фронт
принесе невеликий дощ на півночі.
Також можлива гроза.
Завтра вранці дощі вщухатимуть.
Приблизно на південь від
Зауерланда, Гарца та Берліна
буде дуже сонячно.
У другій половині дня дощ посилиться.
Ввечері можливі грози в низьких гірських хребтах,
а також за Альпами.
Грози також можуть бути сильними.
Якщо ви плануєте поїхати з Берліна,
щоб насолодитися теплом Балтійського моря,
то ви це тепло не застанете.
Адже, як і на Північному морі,
там буде прохолодно - 16°-17°.
У Східній Саксонії чи Верхньому Рейні
температура може підвищитися до 39°.
Новий тиждень почнеться по-літньому,
але вже не так спекотно.
Гарної неділі.